[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres le silence qui parle
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis au les chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 16 septembre un
coup dans le dos un changement de
décision brutale à la trump le chef de
la diplomatie française arrive le drian
ne mâche pas ses mots après la rupture
par l'australie du contrat du siècle
avec la france canberra renonce à
acheter 12 sous marins conventionnels un
manque à gagner pour paris de 56
milliards d'euros une rupture de contrat
qui profite aux états unis et au royaume
uni alors que dit ce changement
d'alliance on en parle dans quelques
minutes avec notre correspondant à
washington
et nos invités
au sommaire également le couple merkel
macron qui partagent ce soir un dernier
dîner de travail à l'elysée
la chancelière allemande est à paris
pour sa tournée d'adieu officiel après
seize années au pouvoir les allemands
doivent désigner son successeur lors des
législatives le 26 septembre prochain
alors que retenir de cette visite en
france quel bilan tirer des relations
franco-allemandes et surtout quel avenir
pour celles ci on en parle dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission
et puis à suivre à 21h une interrogation
et des contradictions emmanuel macron
visage de lever le passé ni terre par
endroits en france
la houle kovy 19 ne circulent plus au
moment où 3000 soignants sont eux
suspendus pour avoir refusé le vaccin de
son côté le ministre de la santé parle
d'une situation sanitaire qui s'améliore
mais semble plus prudent olivier ferrand
qui rappelle que l'épidémie n'est pas
terminée
le ministre qui attend de voir aussi
l'impact de la rentrée scolaire sur les
chiffres
une perte à 56 milliards d'euros un
véritable coup dur pour l'industrie
navale française l'australien confirmé
aujourd'hui la rupture du contrat conclu
en 2016 avec paris pour la fourniture de
12 sous marins conventionnels
canberra s'est finalement rapproché du
royaume-uni et des etats-unis pour se
fournir en sous-marin écouter le premier
ministre australien
aujourd'hui l'australie entame un
partenariat de sécurité trilatérale
renforcé avec le royaume uni et les
etats unis pour permettre une
coopération plus approfondie sur les
capacités de sécurité de défense c'est
une occasion historique pour nos pays de
renforcer la sécurité de donation en des
temps incertains à une rupture au
détriment des sous-marins made in france
mais au profit de ceux fabriqués par les
américains et britanniques alors joe
bagdad at il fait pression on retrouve
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnet bonsoir thomas on a vu donc à que
ce dossier évidemment cristallisé les
tensions entre la france et les états
unis a quand même quelques dizaines de
milliards en jeu dans un premier temps
donc demande des comptes à l'australie
puis vient le moment où la diplomatie
française s'interroge sur le rôle et
l'attitude de washington
oui paris s'est montrée passablement
énervé par rapport à l'attitude donc des
américains alors que un haut responsable
de l'administration de la maison blanche
cité par la fp a expliqué qu'il y avait
eu des contacts justement entre des
hauts responsables de l'administration
américaine et leurs homologues français
a des contacts justement avant cette
annonce qui a été faite hier de cet
accord entre canberra londres et
washington
une affirmation qui a été démenti il ya
quelques instants par l'ambassade de
france aux états unis le porte parole de
l'ambassade a expliqué à l afp que les
services diplomatiques français ici à
washington avait appris la nouvelle de
cet accord donc mené entre les trois
pays vous avez appris cette nouvelle
dans la presse australienne et
américaine on assiste donc à une sorte
de partie de poker menteur entre les
deux pays alliés et sur le fond le chef
de la diplomatie française s'est lui
montré particulièrement virulent à
l'égard de washington une sortie assez
rare de la part d'un ministre français
des affaires étrangères face au puissant
allié américain écouter jean yves le
drian c'était ce matin
c'est vraiment en bon français un coup
dans le dos nous avions établi avec
l'australie une relation de confiance
cette confiance est trahie et je suis
aujourd'hui en colère avec beaucoup
d'amertume sur cette rupture et vous
n'avez pas plus que ça se fait pas entre
alliés et ça ne se fait pas en plus
quand il y à eut d'abord deux ans de
négociations pour ce contrat ce n'est
pas fini parce que il va vers leur des
clarifications nous avons des contrats
il faut que les australiens nous disent
comment ils s'en sortent
nous avons demandé des sommes dues il va
falloir donner des explications nous les
explications de l'argent à bavois et
nous avons un accord intergouvernemental
que nous avons signés en grande pompe en
2019 avec des engagements précis des
articles de ce texte que comment ils
s'en sortent il va falloir qu'ils nous
disent donc on n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire et aux masques 7e épisode
peut laisser des traces pour l'avenir
des relations entre paris et washington
eh bien le communiqué posté cette nuit
par la diplomatie française témoigne
justement de la colère de paris dans ce
dossier vous avez entendu jean yves le
drian qui attend des clarifications qui
a comparé joe biden à son prédécesseur
donald trump il est aussi intéressant de
lire le tweet qui a été postée hier par
l'ambassadeur de france aux états unis
il est souligné le fait que ce mercredi
marquait le 2 son 40e anniversaire d'une
victoire navale des forces françaises
contre les britanniques à cheaspeake bay
une victoire qui avait conduit à
l'indépendance des etats-unis une
manière pour lui de rappeler les liens
historiques très fort entre les deux
pays des liens historiques qui ont été
quelque peu mise à mal ces dernières
heures alors cet épisode elle n'est pas
le premier exemple des relations parfois
compliquées entre paris et washington on
pourra citer par exemple le refus de la
france de participer à la guerre en irak
en 2003 le dossier alstom ou encore les
révélations sur les écoutes menées par
la nsa sur des dirigeants européens mais
cette fois la différence c'est qu'il y
avait un vent d'optimisme qui soufflait
en europe suite à l'élection de joe
biden on a encore en mémoire les images
justement de la tournée européenne à du
locataire de la maison blanche on avait
vu beaucoup de signes de rapprochement
de la part de certains dirigeants
occidentaux qui pour certains n'hésitez
pas non plus à glisser quelques
sous-entendus sur leur phase ii sur la
façon dont ils disent accueilli avec
bienveillance l'élection de joe biden en
comparaison est évidemment avec son
prédécesseur donald trump alors tout ça
est un peu remis en question par cet
épisode de ces dernières heures
évidemment america feu c'était bien ça
reste un mantra pour joe biden comme ça
l'a été pour donald trump faudra voir
maintenant comment vont réagir
concrètement la france et l'europe dont
le passé on a vu parfois des réactions
un petit peu timide de la part des pays
européens on verra si sur ce dossier l
issue est quelque peu différente s'il ya
une nouvelle stratégie à l'échelle du
vieux continent notamment en matière de
défense
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et autres réactions cette
rupture surprise celle moscou la
correspondance en russie d'antoine
clairon la perte du contrat avec les
australiens portant sur l'achat de 12
sous marin reste en travers de la gorge
des autorités françaises le ministre
français des affaires étrangères s'est
même dit en colère avec beaucoup
d'amertume à porte parole de la
diplomatie russe a quant elle réagit aux
propos de jean yves le drian en
rappelant avec ironie l'épisode de la
vente avortée des deux bâtiments de la
marine nationale de classe mistral à la
russie
pourquoi cette colère et cette amertume
la rupture de contrat semble pour la
france être une chose habituelle en 2015
paris avait annulé un contrat avec la
russie sur deux porte hélicoptères
mistral est ce que seuls les couteaux
que vous sentez dans votre propre d'eau
pose problème
en effet en 2015 françois hollande avait
annulé la vente des deux porte
hélicoptères à la russie invoquant la
crise en ukraine paris accusé alors
moscou d'avoir à l'excès la crimée et
d'être impliquées dans le conflit dans
l'est du pays en somme pour maria
sharapova il s'agit ici de l'arroseur
arrosé celui qui rompt un contrat peu à
le recevoir à son tour être la victime
de la même mésaventure et sont indignées
ne peut que prêter à sourire exit donc
cet accord signé en 2016 est qualifié de
contrat du siècle alors que s'est il
passé en coulisses que dit ce revirement
en faveur des américains et sur cette
nouvelle alliance quelle répercussion
sur l'union européenne décryptage avec
nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous en direct pour en parler
françois chauvancy général de brigade
vous est également expert en
géostratégie bonsoir françois chauvancy
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
également charles henri gallois
président du parti génération fréq site
bonsoir charles-henri gallois merci
d'être avec nous tout d'abord je
voudrais vous faire réagir aux
commentaires de jean yves le drian
passablement énervé aujourd'hui cette
décision unilatérales et brutales
ressemble beaucoup à ce que faisait
monsieur trump alors outre l'aspect un
petit peu naïf il faut bien le dire la
france quoi je souffre aussi de cette
dernière remarque qu'on a l'occasion de
notre ministre tombe des nues perdre
comme ça 56 milliards de dollars d'euros
pardon sans être au courant ça paraît
assez incroyable comment c'est possible
on peut se poser la question de savoir
comment c'est possible
dans tous les cas qu'est-ce que ça monte
ça montre le mépris que le monde anglo
saxon parce qu'il faut parler du monde
anglo saxon entre les britanniques entre
les australiens et les états unis envers
la france en particulier et pour réagir
peut-être à l'interview que vous avez
cités précédemment concernant la
position de moscou il faut différencier
dans le cas des contrats
les contrats à conca ce pour des raisons
politiques mais pour raisons politiques
graves et des condamnations comme
c'était le cas pour l'ukraine et la
crimée là en revanche ce n'est pas tout
à fait ça nous sommes dans une affaire
économique et d'un seul coup la
politique grande dans cette économie 1
dans ce rapport économique et on se
retrouve dans une situation où bat on
peut se poser la question est ce qu'il
vaut mieux avoir des ennemis que des
alliés et que la nos meilleurs ennemis
sont bien nos alliés vu la position
qu'ils ont tenu avec ce contrat
la première fois qu'il ya des tensions
entre ses meilleurs ennemis comme vous
dites et ses alliés l'union européenne
déplore elle de ne pas avoir été informé
en nini consultés sur ce pacte de
sécurité conclu entre les états unis
l'australie et le royaume uni justement
pour la région indo pacifique et vanilla
et ses répercussions distille ses
s'éteint un camouflé ça sonne comme un
camouflet clairement charles-henri
gallois pour l'europe oui mais enfin
l'europe moi je distingue à chaque fois
union européenne d europe l'an parle
bien d'une union européenne et l union
européenne une hypocrisie sans nom
puisqu'elle a déjà suivi le projet en
indo pacifique des états unis comme
d'habitude lui européenne un alignement
complet des états unis d'ailleurs la
soumission à l'otan est inscrit dans le
marbre des traités de l'union européenne
et j'irai même plus loin en fait moi ce
qui m'a à ce qui m'a attristé ce qui m'a
désole dans la réaction du gouvernement
français en l'occurrence de jean yves le
drian si vous avez lu le communiqué sa
première réaction plutôt que de tirer
les conséquences en fait de se camoufler
qui est de dire que on doit avant tout
défendre l'indépendance nationale qui
lit avant tout les ce que disait le
général de gaulle en matière plus de
carnaval les états n'ont pas d'amis ils
n'ont que des intérêts sa première
réaction était dire il faut une
autonomie et européennes sous entendant
par là une autonomie en fait de l'union
européenne or il faut revenir un petit
peu en arrière dans le dossier et si on
est sérieux et qu'on regarde le dossier
vous avez vu que le suédois saab et
l'allemand
ktm est ce donc thyssen a fait une
pression aussi colossal en fait pour
torpiller cet accord donc l'union
européenne là dedans et du e-book récent
puisque les allemands eux-mêmes et agit
en sous main pour torpiller cet accord
puisse qu'ils espèrent dévaloriser
d'aval groupe pour eux-mêmes obtenir
justement des désaccords futur pour leur
propre industrie et j'irai même plus
loin vous avez certainement vu il ya un
sénateur australien qui s'appelle rex
patrick qui défend les intérêts
allemands en australie et ça a été un
rouage essentiel en fait pour faire
sauter ces accords donc en fait
l'allemagne a été au coeur du dossier et
après un tel camouflet dire en gros
qu'il faudra insister sur le couple
franco allemand alors que l'allemagne à
chaque fois ne fait que défendre ses
intérêts ça montre l'aspect absolument
nullissime en fait de la stratégie la
diplomatie française qui par dogmatisme
sectaire pour l'union européenne va
vouloir pousser en fait cette défense de
l'union européenne cette union
européenne la défense mais l'union
européenne de défense ce qui n'est rien
d'autre sinon donner toutes les
technologies tout le savoir faire
français et la seule vraie armée dans
l'union européenne sans contrepartie à
l'allemagne donc plutôt de tirer les
leçons en fait de cet échec cuisant on
est parti dans une sorte de fuite en
avant vers une union européenne de la
défense et ça c'est absolument
catastrophique pour les intérêts de la
france
généralement si ça paraît incroyablement
cynique ce qui est en train de nous
expliquer charles-henri gallois ça
promet un dîner ce soir un petit peu
tendu si si ces faits sont avérés n'est
ce pas
oui mais je crois qu'il faut bien
dissocier cette affaire-là de l'union
européenne et de sa défense la question
n'est pas là la question est un contrat
entre la france et l'australie dans un
cadre stratégique et je crois qu'il ce
qu'il faut retenir quand même c'est que
derrière le dos en revanche de la france
en particulier a été monté ce que vous
avez à l'écran actuellement une alliance
stratégique entre la grande bretagne les
états unis et l'australie c'est à dire
que discrètement derrière leurs alliés
ou son allié peu importe une alliance
met en place pour nous évincer de
linteaux pacifique dans lequel nous
avons une stratégie que nous avons
d'ailleurs développé avec l'australie
donc en fait qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'en fait on veut retirer au moins la
france de cette région alors l'union
européenne n'est pas présent union
européenne
ne sert pas à grand chose alors certes
peut-être l'allemagne a un rôle mais
pour l'instant le sujet n'était pas là à
mon avis le sujet était bien le respect
que l'on doit à ses alliés et notamment
dans un cadre stratégique de défense de
sécurité là en l'occurrence ce n'est pas
le cas et je crois que si on doit avoir
confiance en ses alliés c'est pas comme
ça qu'on fait et on parle de bach donne
égale trump je l'avais dit sur votre ex
sur votre chaîne et quelques semaines
j'avais dit la même chose bayh dole
trept même combat c'est america first il
ne faut pas se faire d'illusions nous
l'avons vu en afghanistan on l'a vu
aussi en 2013 avec obama sur la frappe
sur les syriens 1 avec quand même un
vice présidents s'appellent bayonne je
crois surtout qu'il faut reprocher à nos
dirigeants français depuis de nombreuses
années une certaine je dirais
anglophilie anglo saxon i pour dire oui
les américains oui les anglais sont de
grands alliés se sont offert beaucoup de
choses avec eux et ben non elle a
peut-être on revient sur le sujet de
monsieur gallois oui effectivement il
faut penser notre autonomie stratégique
je suis d'accord avec lui ce n'est pas
aux conscient de sécurité à l'union
européenne qu'on arrivera quelque part
il faut déjà que la france donne se
donne les moyens de pouvoir agir mais
soyons concrets au mali nous avons
besoin des américains pour faire une
partie de la guerre donc il faut payer
plus pour avoir une dépense plus et ne
pas compter sur des amis qui n'en sont
pas quand on a besoin d'eux justement
charles-henri galloise sur ce thème on
viendra évidemment sur cette alliance
indo pacifique mais sur ce thème il ya
beaucoup de naïveté de la part des
européens et des français en particulier
notamment sur joe biden parce que ça
fait plusieurs fois la qui se sentent un
petit peu légèrement trahi il ya eu ce
retrait d'afghanistan
voilà il où ils se sont retrouvés un peu
isolé et maintenant voilà c'est fait la
cette rupture de contrat on n'attendait
pas ça de joe biden qui a certainement
dû faire pression lui aussi
oui mais c'était attendu c'est à dire
qu'il ya une naïveté en fait de la
france qui s'alignent systématiquement
sur les choix des états unis à part la
guerre en irak c'est une parenthèse mais
sinon si on prend ça dans le cadre de
l'otan la france à chaque fois
complètement alignés et la grande
problématique on l'a vu il ya eu
l'affairé alsthom il ya eu la sphère des
écoutes dont vous avez parlé il ya eu
évidemment les états unis le royaume uni
et l'allemagne d'ailleurs qui avait fait
pression sur la france pour abandonner
les livraisons des porte hélicoptères
mistral d'ailleurs l'allemagne qui dans
le même temps négocié avec la russie
pour pour mort stream donc on marche sur
la tête la france là dedans et d'une
naïveté confondante et la france en fait
face à un tel camouflet devrait
normalement réagir vis-à-vis des
etats-unis il ya des choses symboliques
en fait qui aurait pu être fait pour
montrer le mécontentement on aurait pu
par exemple donner l'asile politique à
des gens comme edward snowdon comme
julian assange ou même manning serait un
symbole fort en fait pour montrer que la
france cessé d'être alignée sur les
états unis aient cessé de subir en fait
sans rien dire parce que mes
lamentations de jean yves le drian je le
dire mais c'est pathétique parce qu'on
sait très bien que ça va être pas suivi
d'effets et d'ailleurs les américains le
savent très bien c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'ils se permettent de le faire tout
s'est finalement que la france va
rentrer dans le rang et ça c'est
malheureux et c'est le symbole d'un
aliment que les années d'une perte
d'autonomie puisque ça a été dit aussi
évidemment malheureusement la france il
faut investir massivement en défense
puisque on n'est plus capable de faire
des interventions de manière autonome et
si on veut s'émanciper de l'otan ça peut
évidemment commencer par la sortie du
commandement militaire intégré mais pour
sortir complètement de l'otan il faut
que la france soit capable d'avoir une
véritable indépendance nationale et une
autonomie stratégique ce qui n'est plus
le cas à l'heure actuelle et c'est tout
un chantier qui va être mis en place si
la france veut redevenir la france et ne
plus dépendre des autres et ne plus être
la serpillière en fait des états unis en
tout cas pendant que la france pleure le
royaume uni lui rit ainsi que le premier
ministre australien scott morrison on
l'a entendu tout fier tout à l'heure
d'annoncer son nouveau deal écoutez
aussi donc cette réaction de joie non
dissimulée de notre ex partenaire à
boris johnson le royaume uni l'australie
les etats-unis forme d'un nouveau
partenariat de défense trilatérale qui
préservera la sécurité et la stabilité
dans le monde cela créera également des
centaines d'emplois hautement qualifiés
à travers le pays faisant avancer notre
programme de mise à niveau alors
françois changeant six rien que ça un
préserver la sécurité et la stabilité
dans le monde ça veut dire quoi en gros
que face à à la chine l'alliance entre
les les pays anglo-saxons et
j'ai supérieur à l'alliance
transatlantique comme semble d'ailleurs
aussi le penser washington
malheureusement ce qu'on entend d'abord
montre que se fier aux anglais pour
prendre à terme ancien dépôt une bonne
chose cela fait des siècles qu'on doit
pas leur faire confiance et qu'on leur
fait confiance quand même les propos de
ce politicien montre à l'évidence que
cette méfiance doit être entretenu et
qu'on peut pas faire confiance à au
monde britannique au monde anglais
maintenant oui je voulais évoquer tout à
l'heure la stratégie en ado pacifique
était une nécessité face à la chine elle
est une nécessité maintenant si on
devait en tirer des conclusions parce
qu'il faut pas m'en tirer quelques
conclusions si les anglo saxons veulent
mener assurer la sécurité de cette zone
c'est pas la peine demandée à la fin de
le faire ou de participer à leurs
opérations je dirais que s'il y avait
une action pour rejoindre monsieur
gallois parce que on voit effectivement
on a vu un ministre qui parle qui se
plaint qui est triste et bien il faut
des actions c'est quoi l'action déjà
pour commencer nous ne participerons pas
à des alliances wade exercice dans cet
autre ado pacifique avec les anglo
saxons premier temps deuxième temps ban
nous avons six cents australiens à
cherbourg b reprennent l'alto dans 48
heures un pré tour les renvoie chez eux
ça évitera finalement de d'entretenir à
une situation un petit peu délicate il
faut prendre des mesures fortes et c'est
vrai je pense que le gouvernement devra
non pas seulement parler mais agir ici
on veut parle 2-2 autonomie stratégique
mais aussi de souveraineté un jour je me
suis gallois sur ce point là notre
souveraineté s'exprime aussi par des
actes forts quels sont les actes forts
que le gouvernement français fera à
partir de demain ce n'est pas uniquement
en renégociant des contrats ou en ayant
des indemnités c'est qu'est ce que nous
allons faire est là depuis ce matin on
n'entend pas grand chose on se lamente
mais on n'agit pas donc il est temps
d'agir en tout cas anthony blinken
ironie du sort qui disent ce soir la
france reste un partenaire vital dans
cette région indo pacifique donc voilà
croire à qui veut vous qui êtes un
partisan du du fric site charles-henri
gallois c'est le raxit justement qui
vient de de permettre cet accord pour
reprendre le terme de jean yves le drian
d'ailleurs un coup dans le dos
alors je sais pas c'est le brésil en
tant que tel en tout cas ce que cet
accord montre c'est que le brésil on
nous disait que ça allait isoler le
royaume uni du reste du monde pas du
tout on voit qu'ils font des alliances
en fonction de leurs intérêts et
notamment dans la sphère anglo saxon
donc ça c'était attendu et le royaume
uni n'est pas isolé la problématique
c'est le royaume uni défend ses intérêts
il en a bien le droit mais la france
devrait défendre ses intérêts et on voit
bien que dans cette fuite en avant qui
est l'union européenne de la défense ou
la france va encore sacrifier tous
intéressants contrepartie par exemple
pour l'allemagne la france fait tout le
contraire ne défend pas ses intérêts ou
à la rigueur ça ne me dérange pas que
les autres pays défendent leurs intérêts
c'est le sait la logique du monde d'un
problématique c'est que la france ne le
fait pas et c'est entre autres parce
qu'on est
perverti par ce logiciel en fait et ce
dogme de l'union européenne lui dit que
la france par grande générosité devrait
tout donner aux autres mais tous les
autres pays et les pays au sein de
l'union européenne défende avant tout
leur intérêt et on attend normalement
d'un gouvernement on va attendre un chef
de l'état qui est élu par les français
qui défendent les intérêts de la france
et les français et malheureusement on
voit que ce n'est pas le cas il ya la
volonté en fait de la france de
reprendre le contrôle d'un point de vue
la défense mais sur tous les sujets
c'est absolument vital si on veut que la
france soit un pays qui compte au 21ème
siècle est normalement c'est la vocation
de la france est et on attend que ce
soit le cas merci beaucoup à tous les
deux charles-henri gallois françois
chavance y d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage ce soir
la france qui perd le contrat du chèque
mais qui gagnent tout de même une
bataille aujourd'hui sur le front de la
lutte anti-terrorisme numéro un des
shows grand sahara naboo walid al
sahraoui a été tué par l'armée française
l'homme aurait succombé à une frappe
militaire qui a eu lieu il y a quelques
semaines une nouvelle qui intervient
dans un contexte tendu entre paris et la
junte au pouvoir au mali en pleine
opération barque à naucelle le point
avec les mines à benzaïd à
sa tête était mise à prix le chef du
groupe etat islamique au grand sahara
adnan abou walid al sahraoui est mort
des suites de ses blessures à l'origine
une frappe française datant du mois
d'août selon la ministre des armées
florence parly ce jeudi la mort de celui
que l'on nomme l'ennemi numéro 1 est
officiel adnan abou walid al sahraouis
chef du groupe terroriste état islamique
au grand sahara a été neutralisé par les
forces françaises il s'agit d'un nouveau
succès majeur dans le combat que nous
menons contre les groupes terroristes au
sahel la diplomatie française l'accusé
d'avoir été l'auteur de la plupart des
attaques dans la zone des trois
frontières
ce vaste espace à cheval sur le mali le
niger et le burkina faso au coeur de la
zone d'intervention de la force barkan
c'est une figure historique
du djihad au sahel c'est lui qui a créé
la filiale sahélienne de dèche en 2015
c'est un émir autoritaire autocrate
il était le chef absolu de la sgs et
prenait toutes les décisions
je peux vous confirmer
que celle émir de l'aïs gs qui avait
personnellement ordonné la tacc de cours
et qui a conduit à l'assassinât de six
français
humanitaire de l'om j'ai acte aide et de
leur guide nigérien c'était le 9 août
adnan abou walid al sahraoui a été
membre du front polisario le groupe
indépendantiste du sahara occidental
avant d'intégrer la mouvance djihadiste
au sahel aqmi la région des trois
frontières est la cible d'attaqués
récurrentes depuis plusieurs années deux
groupes armés djihadistes concurrents
notamment le groupe etat islamique au
grand sahara et le groupe de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans
principal soutien à al qaïda alors avec
la mort d'anna abou walid sahraoui c'est
la tête de l'un d'entre eux qui tombe
mais cela ne marque pas pour autant la
fin du groupe etat islamique au sahara
nous avons dit le geste est aujourd'hui
durablement affaibli dans la zone des
trois frontières mais nous n'avons pas
dit que ses capacités de l'exister plus
après huit ans de présence militaire
française au sahel emmanuel macron a
annoncé en juin une réduction des
troupes et la fin de l'opération anti
djihadistes barkan au profit d'un
dispositif resserré centrée sur les
opérations de contre-terrorisme et
l'accompagnement des armées locales
autour d'une alliance européenne
associant divers contingents de forces
spéciales
et on va plus loin avec pierre martinet
directeur de wind corp c'est qu'ils
auraient été défense bonsoir pierre
martinet merci d'être avec nous pourquoi
tout d'abord anne abou walid el sahraoui
était une cible prioritaire
eh bien il fait partie de toutes les
deux la grande liste des cibles
prioritaires ça fait partie des voies
dire de l'échelon supérieur de ces
groupes islamistes et c'était un chef
parmi d'autres temps d'autres qui
étaient particulièrement
ciblés depuis plusieurs années il était
particulièrement virulent à sanguinaire
d'après son portrait entre guillemets
donc il est important déjà sur le plan
sur le plan du combat qu'on mène contre
la ba de couper les têtes au fur et à
mesure qu'on les combats c'est important
de le neutraliser même si faut pas se
leurrer demain il sera remplacé mais il
n'empêche que ça c'est alors ça reporte
un coup d'arrêt quand même un coup
d'arrêt sur le plan militaire et les
coups d'arrêt idéologique parce qu'il
avait sondé son idéologie particulière
et un coup d'arrêt morales vient de vino
clairement c'est aussi on imagine une
annonce très politique alors que que la
france dans le même temps annoncé le
retrait du sel après la débâcle aussi en
afghanistan une manière de dire regardez
on part du sel mais on reste efficace et
il faudra surtout compter avec nous au
mali
alors il va y avoir un retrait du mali
progressivement mais il va y avoir une
régulation de des forces spéciales sur
les trois pays est concerné niger
burkina faso et mali
je pense que la lutte contre le contrôle
l'aspect militaire en matériaux entre
guillemets de du projet islamiste
pour moi sera encore de très longue
durée voire sans fin non pour en
reparler dans 19 ans ou 30 ans
mais on peut pas rester une force une
force conventionnelle ne peut pas rester
au mali encore 10 15 ans pour donner ce
qu'on retrouve quand notre convoi qu'on
a vus ou jeudi en afghanistan je pense
qu'au mali on a peur que la zone
malienne
burkina et mallet niger deviennent
l'afghanistan deux africains parce que
si toutes les forces françaises
occidentales parce qu'il ya un peu d'âme
il ya peu d'occident d'occidentaux
là-bas se retire la nature a dit avoir
dû vider veille avoir automatiquement
des groupes islamistes qui vont qui vont
qui vont encore plus prendre le pouvoir
dans certaines régions plus se répandre
et dans le même temps la france
d'une certaine manière souhaite aussi
faire cavalier pas seul parce qu'elle a
ses alliés sur place quoique aujourd'hui
on voit qu'il ya quelques tensions aussi
avec les alliés mais on suivait la
sphère d'hyères où jean-yves le drian
déclaré absolument incompatibles la
présence notamment du groupe militaire
wagner russe sur place bien que la
russie ait démenti ça veut dire voilà on
est là c'est un message aussi envoyé à
l'argentin malienne
alors les relations avec la jeune
malienne c'est vrai sont sont tendues en
revanche pour avoir fait déjà à des
débats sur ce sujet sur notre plateau je
crois
le cnt malien ne peut pas forcément que
l'ensemble de la de la force par scan se
retire ce ils veulent qui est qu'elle
soit moins visibles et qui n'auraient
articulations
de 7,2 cette force au mali pour que la
population malienne ne se sent pas entre
guillemets occupé par par la france donc
c'est un petit peu ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut
adoucira rendirent l'exemple
effectivement il ne faudrait pas que le
mali deviennent aussi la centrafrique
parce que je vous dis propos pour info
la fin de la centrafrique c'est le
groupe wagner qui a qui est entre
guillemets au pouvoir et
les centrafricains aujourd'hui
commencent à déchanter de la présence de
ce groupe là en chez eux parce que c'est
ils se servent sur la bête comment comme
on dit chez nous et ils sont allés au
manettes de beaucoup d'entreprises là
bas ils saluent la centrafrique
commencer un petit peu et tout et tout
ferry wagner donc je pense que wagner
c'est pas une bonne idée au mali
quel impact pourrait avoir la
disparition en tout cas de de ce chef
vous dites il va quoi qu'il arrive être
remplacé et il y aura t'il quand même un
bénéfice à court terme
un bénéfice à très court terme bénéfices
sur le mois et déjà passé parce que il a
été il a été drone est entre guillemets
il ya déjà quelques quelques jours donc
il est peut-être sur le point d'être
remplacé mais c'est quand même c'est
quand même un marqueur c'est quand même
un impact psychologique sur ces groupes
islamistes ça veut dire qu'on peut les
maintenant ce qui est intéressant dans
cette dans cette élimination c'est qu'on
peut dire que c'est une opération aux
mots pourquoi parceque il a été localisé
par a priori d'après ce que j'ai pu lire
il a été localisé par via son téléphone
par des américains et les français l'ont
frappé avec un drone donc les français
disposent aujourd'hui je pas de 1 ou 2
drones armés c'est une nouveauté ça on
n'en parle pas tellement mais
aujourd'hui les français sont capables
de frapper
des
djihadistes à distance et ensuite ils
ont envoyé des forces pour pour pour
confirmer cette la cible mais c'est
assez nouveau parce qu'il ya un décalage
quand même avec ce qu'on entend en
france c'est un parallèle que je fais à
chaque fois mais là bas ou manière on
les capture pas pour les juger on les
tue sans jugement alors qu'en france
vous avez vu tous les djihadistes on est
on est on essaie de les capturer pour
les juges il ya un vrai décalage entre
temps sa bière qui globalement il faut
pas dissocier ce qui se passe en europe
et ce qui se passe en afrique pour moi
c'est exactement la même chose et c'est
pour ça qu'on est quand même le entre le
marteau et l'enclume parce qu'on
n'arrive pas en france a
repoussé ces djihadistes de façon
idéologique donc on est coincé je pense
avec nos droits de l'homme et notre
justice qui est bien ou pas bien ça
c'est chacun se fera son idée mais il ya
une nouveauté aujourd'hui c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on ne connaît en drones
les les djihadistes en afrique issa je
trouve que c'est pas mal parce que ça
allait vite des pertes chez nous merci
pierre martinet d'avoir apporté votre
analyse en direct sur rt france
et dans les qualités internationales
également au moins 50 morts au yémen
dans nos nombreux affrontements au cours
des dernières 24 heures parmi les
victimes des rebelles houthi et des
soldats progouvernementaux soutenu par
la coalition emmenées par l'arabie
saoudite ces dernières semaines les
insurgés appuyés par l'iran progresser
dans le centre du pays des combats qui
durent depuis sept ans et qui pèsent sur
l'économie du yémen une population prise
au piège et qui manifeste depuis
plusieurs jours dans plusieurs villes du
sud pour demander de meilleures
conditions de vie hélène masquelier
plusieurs centaines de personnes dans
les rues d'aden des citoyens en colère
manifestent depuis quelques jours dans
les grandes villes du sud du pays pris
dans l'étau d'un conflit qui dure depuis
sept ans ils dénoncent la dégradation de
leurs conditions de vie
nous manifestons aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer l'injustice que nous vivons
ils disent que la valeur du dollar a
baissé puisqu'elle a augmenté est-ce que
c'est logique
[Musique]
mon salaire est de 30 mille rigal
comment est ce que je peux vivre pour
acheter de l'essence il nous faut au
moins dix mille et rial
dans ces conditions comment les gens
peuvent-ils s'alimenter et élever leurs
enfants je ne soutiens ni le coup d'état
ni le gouvernement ils doivent partir et
laisser le peuple organisé sa vie de
façon autonome
nous sommes venus ici pour réclamer
notre droit
[Musique]
tout le monde doit partir les outils le
conseil de transition et le gouvernement
nous allons nous confronter à eux
rebelles houthi ou gouvernement même
combat pour ses citoyens
augmentation du coût de la vie chômage
effondrement de la monnaie par rapport
au dollar ou encore coupures de courant
de plus en plus fréquentes les habitants
subissent de plein fouet les
conséquences de ces affrontements et les
relations du pays avec l'étranger sont
aussi affectés l'aéroport international
de la capitale sanaa aux mains des
outils est fermé depuis cinq ans ce
mercredi des manifestants sont venus
demander sa réouverture
la mobilisation d'aujourd'hui vise à
lever la fermeture de l'aéroport car
nous sommes des citoyens yéménites et
britanniques
nos familles et nos enfants pâtissent
beaucoup de cette fermeture pour arriver
à sanaa les gens doivent transiter par
plusieurs points et ce pendant quatre ou
cinq jours
une lassitude et un dégoût généralisée
des citoyens qui cherchent à survivre
dans un pays plongé dans un conflit donc
personne ne voit l'issue la guerre entre
les rebelles et les forces pro
gouvernementales a provoqué selon l'onu
la pire crise humanitaire au monde avec
des citoyens au bord de la famine sur
les 30 millions d'habitants que compte
le pays 80 % dépendent désormais de
l'aide internationale
est toujours au moyen orient le liban
est plus que jamais en pleine pénurie de
carburant tôt ce matin un convoi d'une
dizaine de camions citernes transportant
du diesel iranien a franchi la frontière
entre la syrie et le 7 le pays du cèdre
une raison organisée par le mouvement
chiite pro iranien hezbollah et ce en
dépit des sanctions américaines qui
frappent téhéran
c'est une victoire pour le peuple
libanais qui a été humilié pour avoir
demandé un peu de pétrole et de
carburants c'est une victoire pour tout
le peuple libanais tout secteur confondu
de chaque personne qui dit être une
balèze reste fier j'espère qu'elle sera
toujours fier tout cela grâce à sayyed
et au son des martyrs
c'est un grand pas en avant nous
espérons que notre pas suivra comme par
exemple l'apport de carburant espérons
que le gouvernement assurera
l'électricité et jouera son rôle en
portons idée d la résistance qui a pris
l'initiative d'aidé pour le peuple
libanais et pas seulement les habitants
des bas blake et r'mel
plus d'un mois et demi après le coup de
force du président kaïs saïd au nom de
la lutte anti-corruption la tunisie est
toujours enlisé dans une grave crise
politique
luge et était puissante centrale
syndicale qui a soutenu le chef de
l'état dans son projet de changement
semble perdre patience la correspondance
à tunis de banshee
c'est un communiqué qui résonne comme un
coup de pression celui de la puissante
centrale syndicale tunisienne et lui
jette était au président kaïs sayed et
l'union générale tunisienne du travail
premier syndicat du pays avaient dès le
25 juillet apporté son soutien au
président de la république lors de son
coup de force mais voilà avec un mois et
demi plus tard tout comme de nombreux
tunisiens lui gtt commence à
s'impatienter dans un communiqué publié
hier le bureau exécutif de luge et et a
de nouveau appelé à la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement restreint ainsi
qu'à la fin des mesures exceptionnelles
et à la mise en place d'une gouvernance
basée sur une légitimité populaire
écouter il est urgent d'accélérer la
formation d'un gouvernement restreint
avec pour rôle de traiter les dossiers
économiques sociaux et sanitaires de
garantir la continuité de l'état et de
mettre à exécution ses engagements tout
retard en la matière mène à
l'approfondissement de la crise au
démantèlement de l'état et en menacent
l'existence
la centrale syndicale a notamment
insisté sur l'importance du dialogue
social en tunisie et a rappelé les
acquis de la révolution notamment par la
même occasion la nécessité d'éviter le
recours à la justice militaire en ce qui
concerne les affaires civiles alors que
de nombreux partis politiques avocats ou
encore membres de la société civile ont
dénoncé le projet de réforme de la
constitution envisagé pour le chef de
l'état élu gtt semble ne plus pouvoir
caché son inquiétude face à un cahier ça
y est bien décidé à faire cavalier seul
faisant fi de toute critique ou menace
du côté de carthage les annonces
officielles se font rares le conseiller
à la présidence de la république quaïda
jammes a laissé entendre sur une chaîne
de télévision étrangère
l'acca nouveau gouvernement pourrait
être annoncé dans les prochains jours
angela merkel est en ce moment à
l'elysée la chancelière allemande
partage son dernier dîner de travail
avec emmanuel macron la chancelière qui
s'apprête à faire ses adieux au pouvoir
fin septembre l'occasion de mettre en
scène à paris la proximité politique en
caux allemande on en parle tout de suite
avec notre reporter lucas léger devant
l'elysée bonsoir oui car avant d'aller
dîner les deux dirigeants ont tenu une
conférence de presse que peut-on retenir
les deux dirigeants ont parlé pendant
cinq minutes environ tous les deux
emmanuel macron attendait en gala merkel
sur le perron de l'elysée cette
rencontre ça pourrait bien effectivement
être la dernière à paris entre les deux
dirigeants en tant que dirigeant puisque
les élections auront lieu au bundestag
le 26 septembre et que angela merkel ne
brigue pas un autre mandat elle va donc
quitter ses fonctions après presque 16
ans de règne ininterrompu quoi qu'il en
soit les deux dirigeants aujourd'hui ont
tenu à préciser que ce n'était pas
encore l'heure des adieux et que la
réunion était une réunion de travail je
vous propose de les écouter j'ai comme
vous conscience des échéances politiques
des prochaines semaines en allemagne que
la france ferrique attention mais d'ici
à la formation du prochain gouvernement
madame la chancelière angela merkel et
moi même continuerons à travailler main
dans la main sur les grands dossiers
auxquels nous cherchons à apporter des
solutions franco allemande comme nous le
faisons depuis le premier jour bien sûr
les élections
législatives en allemagne vont amener à
la constitution d'un nouveau
gouvernement mais nous ferons tout ce
qui est en notre pouvoir pour éviter
qu'il y ait une période de latence trop
longue menu aujourd'hui un planning
chargé notamment des discussions sur
l'iran la libye l'ukraine la biélorussie
les questions climatiques les questions
numériques la préparation d'un sommet
entre l'union européenne et les balkans
occidentaux à lubjana le 16 octobre et
la future présidence de l'union
européenne la future présidence
française de l'union européenne qui doit
être préparé puisque elle aura lieu au
premier semestre 2011 22 mais surtout la
question principale à aujourd'hui qui a
été mise en avant par les dirigeants ses
seuls de l'afghanistan et de l'accueil
des réfugiés je vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'on a dit angela merkel les thèmes
de l'afghanistan va beaucoup nous
préoccuper
la question c'est évidemment de savoir
comment nous pouvons faire sortir
d'afghanistan des personnes éligibles
rapatriement ou des réfugiés comment les
mettre en sécurité au cours de leur
mandat comment les deux dirigeants n'ont
pas toujours eu des relations très
facile mais ils ont toujours affiché une
entente je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'en disait emmanuel macron en 2017
on se parle au moins une à deux fois par
semaine depuis que je suis élu on
s'envoie des messages très régulièrement
et nous avons eu beaucoup de réunions
ensemble j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
elle même si nous avons des différences
malgré ses déclarations emmanuel macron
prépare tout de même la praye merkel il
à dire d'ores et déjà reçu à l'elysée
les deux plus probable successeur de la
chancelière allemande le
social-démocrate au lost olaf scholz et
le démocrate-chrétien armin laschet tu
merci du quai léger en direct devant
l'elysée et pour aller plus loin nous
sommes en direct avec frédéric viale
spécialiste des questions européennes
bonsoir frédéric viale merci à d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france est
donc le dernier dîner de travail ce soir
pour angela merkel et emmanuel macron
tout d'abord que retenez-vous de ce
couple franco allemand
en réalité le couple franco allemand
n'existe pas ça va peut-être vous
sembler étrange ce que je dis mais
normalement dans un couple il ya une
certaine égalité cdmm parité en fait
dans un véritable couple or là ce qui se
passe depuis beaucoup d'années et bien
avant même l'élection de maquereaux
c'est que l'allemagne domine très
largement dans l'union européenne et
domine très largement la france et ça ça
vient du fait que nos élites politiques
et administratives en tous les cas en
france sont totalement énamouré du
modèle allemand et coll constamment à la
roue de ce que veulent et de ce que
exige en réalité les allemands et donc à
partir de là il y a une véritable
domination
de l'allemagne à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et dans ce pseudo couple
franco allemand qui fait qu' on peut
dire aujourd'hui que non ce n'est pas
réellement des relations paritaire des
relations égalitaires c'est
véritablement une façon de faire des
élites politiques françaises qui
consiste à coller constamment vers la
politique allemande pas spécialement
liés si on vous comprend bien au couple
macron merkel mais intrinsèquement
finalement au couple franco allemand et
ça depuis plusieurs années oui bien en
théorie vous avez excellemment bien
compris c'est à dire que c'est bien
avant macron c'est vraiment structurel
depuis en réalité au moins la création
de l'euro pour tout un tas de raisons
l'euro a été taillée
comme le souhaitait l'allemagne de
l'époque et globalement on a un euro qui
facilite les excédents commerciaux
structurel de l'allemagne et les
excédents commerciaux structurel de
l'allemagne se tombe ce sont les
déficits commerciaux de la france aussi
largement en partie en tous les cas et
cela la france aucun président depuis
chirac n'a voulu remettre ça en cause et
n'a voulu mettre ce problème là sur la
table à partir de là on a véritablement
des relations très très inégalitaire et
finalement ce qui s'est passé le couple
entre merkel et makro ça n'a pas
tellement d'importance en réalité leur
relation personnelle puisque elles sont
totalement déterminée par la structure
même des relations franco allemande
angela merkel va donc laisser sa place
fin septembre après seize années au
pouvoir
quel bilan tirer de ces mandats dans son
rapport quand même avec avec la france
l'allemagne a réussi à exporter sa
politique au redoux libéral et à
l'imposer d'une certaine façon à la
france enfin quand je dis à l'imposer
nos élites bureaucratiques et politique
étaient bien d'accord pour ça bon mais
en tous les cas la politique
de faible coût des salaires de faible
coût du travail a été largement importée
vers la france et le résultat tout ça
c'est qu'on a des politiques d'austérité
y compris en france qui se poursuivent
alors que ce sont des politiques qui
sont fondamentalement inefficace
économiquement et injustes socialement
ça veut dire si on suit votre
raisonnement que quel que soit le futur
dirigeant allemand ça ne va rien changer
sur cette relation déséquilibrée
oui les chances que ça ne change pas
sauf si il y à un prochain dirigeant
français qui à l'élection européenne sa
part dont l'élection présidentielle
excusez moi soit capable de remettre en
cause ce pseudo couple franco-allemand
est de mettre un certain nombre de
problèmes sur la table notamment celui
d'aider des excédents commerciaux
considérables de l'allemagne et que etc
et ça ça voudrait dire un changement de
politique extérieure de la france et ça
serait très très important de discuter
de cela dans l'élection présidentielle
évidemment ça veut dire nécessairement
un futur président ou présidente
souverainiste dans ce cas le seul moyen
de s'affranchir six ans c'est encore une
fois va trop logique
si on suit ma logique oui absolument
c'est à dire que bon ça c'est pas secret
mais effectivement je pense que la
retrouver la souveraineté de la france
pour une essayer de faire en sorte
qu'elle se reconstruise est absolument
nécessaire et c'est l'enjeu de la
prochaine élection présidentielle la
prochaine élection présidentielle c'est
pas l'enjeu identitaire c'est parce que
raconte zemmour c'est parce que raconte
l'extrême droite l'âge est le véritable
enjeu c'est pour la france de recouvrer
sa souveraineté merci beaucoup aux
frédéric viale un spécialiste des
questions européennes merci d'avoir aidé
réveil nous avoir porté votre analyse
l'union européenne où la question d'une
sortie de lieux de la pologne qui
s'invite dans le débat et ce alors que
les réformes judiciaires polonaises ont
été sanctionnés par bruxelles le parti
ultra conservateur au pouvoir dénonce la
dictature bureaucratique de bruxelles
amaya souple et
la pologne est catégorique elle ne
compte pas sortir de l'union européenne
une annonce faite par le vice premier
ministre et chef du parti droit et
justice
bien que les relations entre varsovie et
bruxelles se complexifie depuis
plusieurs semaines
ils dénoncent l'ingérence de l'union
européenne dans les affaires intérieures
du pays et réclame le respect de la
souveraineté de la pologne il n'y aura
pas de paul excite c'est une idée de
propagande qui a été utilisé à maintes
reprise contre nous nous voyons
clairement l'avenir de la pologne dans
l'union européenne
il faut ajouter ici que les questions d
administration de la justice reste de la
compétence exclusive des états et ne
peuvent faire l'objet de type
d'ingérence qui se produit actuellement
la semaine dernière la cour de justice
de l'union européenne a sanctionné la
pologne au sujet de sa réforme
judiciaire trop lente selon bruxelles
les systèmes judiciaires de l'union
européenne doivent être indépendants et
équitable les droits des citoyens
européens doit être garantie de la même
manière où qu'ils vivent dans l'union
européenne en ligne de mire la chambre
disciplinaire qui ne respectent pas
l'état de droit
c'est à la cus cet organe de mettre en
péril l'indépendance des juges au profit
de l'exécutif sans tenir compte du
principe démocratique de la séparation
des pouvoirs
l'union européenne a ordonné des
changements au sein de cette structure
le 14 juillet dernier mais varsovie joue
la montre si le pays ne respecte pas ses
nombreuses promesses de réformes rapides
bruxelles pourrait lui infliger des
sanctions financières d'ici à six mois
la direction présents le royaume uni où
le premier ministre boris johnson a
remanié hier son gouvernement alors que
la popularité des conservateurs n'est
pas au mieux entre la gestion nuque au
vide ou celle de la crise afghane le
gouvernement a été fortement critiqué le
chef de la diplomatie dominique rabat
donc changer de poste et trois ministres
clés ont été remplacés et précision de
walid bennani
dominique râble sous les feux de la
rampe le chef de la diplomatie
britannique a rendez vous avec son
supérieur une épée de damoclès au-dessus
de la tête
sourire de circonstance dominique rab
quitte le 10 downing street dans la peau
du nouveau ministre de la justice le
libéral de 47 ans au coeur d'une partie
d'échecs orchestrée par boris johnson le
premier ministre en chute dans les
sondages est dans l'obligation de réagir
aux dernières polémiques dominique rab
pointé du doigt pour ne pas avoir
raccourci ses vacances alors que kaboul
tomber dans les mains des talibans le 15
août
avec le recul je ne serais pas partie en
vacances mais le recul est un luxe
inaccessible
quand êtes vous parti en vacances
franchement crise je ne vais pas
commencer à m'aventurer dans une liste
de détails je m'en tiens au fait
exploser dans mon compte rendu complet
j'ai déjà répondu à de très nombreuses
questions
ce
même si dominique rab conserve son titre
de vice premier ministre il est remplacé
aux affaires étrangères parle istres us
46 ans une pièce fort sur l'échiquier de
boris johnson au commerce extérieur elle
a réussi à nouer des liens commerciaux
avec le japon l'australie ou encore le
vietnam des liens précieux dans l'ère
post préc site
l'image du royaume uni ébranlé le
locataire du 10 downing street a décidé
de mettre en place je cite une équipe
forte et unie le populaire richy sounac
41 ans conserve son poste aux finances
pretty batel est elle maintenue à
l'intérieur malgré sa gestion
controversée des migrants illégaux qui
tentent la traversée de la manche
boris johnson continuent d'être
surveillés sur sa gestion de la pandémie
il se passe pourtant du secrétaire
d'état chargé de la vaccination nadhim
zahawi très apprécié outre manche pour
avoir permis la vaccination de 80% de la
population adulte britannique
il quitte cette mission pour basculer à
l'éducation ait pris ce match par le
public à feu je pense qu'il vaut mieux
être prudent que d'entreprendre un
programme de vaccination d'une manière
qui n'est peut être pas appropriée nous
disposons de certains des meilleurs
conseils clinique au monde et je pense
qu'il est juste que nous les écoutions
et que nous procédions aussi prudemment
que possible au risque de passer d'une
situation pandémique à endémique
en pleine double crise à la fois
sanitaire et économique
boris johnson dit se fixer pour objectif
d'unir et de relever l'ensemble du pays
chine qui
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du pass sanitaire en
france emmanuel macron envisage de lever
par endroits là où le co vide ne
circulent plus au moment où 3000
soignants sont suspendus pour avoir
refusé le vaccin de son côté le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand rappelle que
l'épidémie n'est pas terminée décryptage
avec nos invités
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions tout du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare impossible pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent psycho la
lancée de ses pilotes donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et on voir pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plutôt calme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
à
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont il désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus que nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moissac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
cette dernière année a été plutôt
heureuse pour les bouches les bourses
mondiales alors que la crise sanitaire
on n'est pas tout à fait terminée
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
cette hausse vous avez le les banques
centrales qui déversent des liquidités
massivement et les flèches vers la
bourse aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
aucune corrélation entre l'activité
réelle le pib et les marchés financiers
le jour où les banques centrales ont
décidé de tout arrêter tous les marchés
leur reviendront à la réalité on risque
d'avoir justement un éclatement de la
bulle est aujourd'hui l'action des
banques centrales est bien plus pervers
que ça parce qu'elle détruit l'économie
réelle de nos jours il n'ya aucun trader
qui n'ose aller contrer le marché parce
que l'afsset force en question qu'est la
force de des banques centrales est trop
forte
[Musique]
mecili dette on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique
coloniale et et devenir un territoire et
prendre les enfants sans le consentement
des parents et les arachides leur
territoire pour les amis dans d'autres
régions dans deux provinces très très
loin l'objectif est de nature il a
étudié dans la fin juin justement 182
tombes anonymes ont été découvertes sur
le site d'un ancien pensionnat à
cranbrook en colombie britannique
et c'est la troisième découverte de ce
type en un mois on parle ici de génocide
de politique génocidaire sa voix au delà
de la culture mais plutôt un crime
contre
l'humanité obsède une nation
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission elle a
une une interrogation et des
contradictions et manomètres envisage de
lever le passé ni terre par endroits en
france là où locaux vides ne circulent
plus au moment où 3000 soignante été
suspendu pour avoir refusé le vaccin de
son côté le ministre de la santé parle
d'une situation sanitaire qui s'améliore
mais semble plus prudent olivier ferrand
qui rappelle que l'épidémie n'est pas
terminée le ministre qui attend de voir
aussi l'impact de la rentrée scolaire
sur les chiffres
[Musique]
est tout d'abord un mot sur l'état des
lieux de la situation sanitaire en
france
9144 nouveau 4 kobe 80 décès enregistrés
sur les dernières 24 heures la quatrième
vague qui sont marquer le pas après en
avoir évoqué l'hypothèse hier le
président macron a confirmé qu'un
prochain allègement des mesures
pourraient intervenir dans les
prochaines semaines nicholas pettit
retrouver les terrasses des cafés et
restaurants c'est possible à la
condition seulement de présenter le pass
sanitaire rendu obligatoire depuis le 9
août dernier emmanuel macron a évoqué ce
jeudi la possibilité de l'alléger
dès que les conditions sanitaires le
permettrons va lever certaines
contraintes et donc levé le pass là où
le virus ne circule plus vu les chiffres
ce ne sera pas si tard si demain on peut
arrêter le pass sanitaire je suis le
plus heureux des hommes ça a été une
stratégie payante pour se faire vacciner
selon le président cette levée de
certaines contraintes pourraient être
décidées localement dans les
départements où la situation sanitaire
le permettraient mais avant de crier
victoire olivier ferrand qui s'est
exprimé plus tôt dans la matinée préfère
tempérer les espoirs en rappelant que
tout dépend de la dynamique épidémique
et qu'il est encore trop tôt pour
envisager la levée du pass sanitaires
si les chiffres des contaminations sont
en baisse et le nombre de patients admis
en réanimation passé sous le seuil des
2000 les effets de la rentrée scolaire
ne sont à ce stade pas encore connue et
pourrait se ressentir dans les prochains
jours ces annonces interviennent alors
que l'obligation vaccinale dans
certaines professions comme celles des
soignants et elle en vigueur depuis
mercredi de quoi faire réagir une partie
de l'opposition
j'ai toujours été contre le pass
sanitaires j'ai voté contre à
l'assemblée nationale et à chaque fois
que j'ai été interrogé j'ai exprimé à
quel point cette mesure ma paraît
disproportionnée ainsi que toutes les
conséquences qu'elle implique on se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans une situation
insensée
selon les chiffres communiqués ce jeudi
par le ministre de la santé 3000
soignant non vaccinés ont été suspendus
de leurs fonctions des chiffres qui
pourraient être sous-estimée 1500
suspension de postes auraient été
rapportés rien que dans une quinzaine
d'hôpitaux publics
et on se dirige donc vers un allègement
des contraintes sanitaires dans certains
départements une bonne nouvelle pour
certains mais des interrogations sur la
stratégie gouvernementale pour lutter
contre le kobe 19 reste bien vague on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
éditorialiste alexis poulain bonsoir
alexis et on commence tout de même par
des constats ça fait du bien un petit
peu plutôt réjouissant le coville en
france clairement la situation
s'éclaircit et s'améliore à ce stade oui
alors à ce stade moins de 2000 personnes
sont en réanimation
1900 environ et les chiffres depuis
quelques semaines sont du côté de la
baisse c'est à dire que soit la campagne
de vaccination a fonctionné soit le
passenger fonctionner soit le virus est
moins virulent toutefois et il est
question maintenant de revoir
effectivement l'ajustement de ses
politiques sanitaires parce que les
chiffres sont bons et tant mieux je
pense qu'après deux ans de kovy d'un
rappelez-vous décembre 2019 covit 19
maintenant nous allons bientôt arriver
en octobre 2021 il est temps de passer à
autre chose et évidemment la vaccination
est arrivé entre temps les connaissances
aussi sur ce virus la façon dont il le
mute dont il
occupent les corps des humains
permettent aujourd'hui de se dire qu'en
france on peut quand même commencé à
faire autre chose le pass annie terre il
a été mis en place pendant l'été pour
éviter que la rentrée soit une
catastrophe
de de contamination est évidemment il y
a eu 3000
pas trop mais je n'ai pas le chiffre
exact mais il y beaucoup de classes
fermées mais finalement on a
l'impression que la rentrée n'est pas
l'explosion de l'épidémie qui aurait pu
être la crainte des soignants certains
parlaient de 50000 contamination par
jour dans les écoles on est loin de ce
cas on est loin de cette de ces chiffres
là et heureusement et donc emmanuel
macron peut lâcher la bride et dire que
éventuellement se passe à l'inter va
être allégé dans les semaines qui
viennent autre raison aussi c'est que la
reprise économique ne pourra pas être au
rendez-vous si le passe à lithaire est
toujours présent et toujours aussi
pesant que ce soit sur le secteur bien
sûr du divertissement des restaurants et
du reste il faut aujourd'hui que les
français retrouvent une sorte de vie
normale même si elle ne sera pas normal
puisque le covin est toujours présent
donc gestes-barrières le masque de la
vaccination est aujourd'hui est-ce que
le le passé littéraire encore un sens
oui selon certains mais pour un
président en campagne il est temps
peut-être de lever les barrières alors
ce qui nous conduit tout de même à une
question alexis avec notre esprit retors
à vous et à moi emmanuel macron ne
fait-il pas tout même une nouvelle fois
dû en même temps d'un côté 3000
soignants suspendu de l'autre le pass
alléger
alors on n'a pas l'esprit retors je
pense qu'on est simplement critiques et
qu'on fait un travail exigeant de
journalisme et le journalisme c'est quoi
c'est poser des questions au moment où
il faut poser des questions et apporter
des réponses avec des preuves
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
d'un côté olivier rang mais ils seront
de la santé est très fier de dire que
3000 soignants ont été suspendues parce
qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés et que
plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux
alors je pense que les chiffres sont
revues à la baisse d'ailleurs ont
démissionné le problème c'est que quand
on m'a d'été le chiffre est con ministre
de la santé on ne peut pas s'en réjouir
ça veut dire que l'hôpital est en train
de s'effondrer que il ya des services
qui vont fermer que ce soit des dialyses
que ce soit les services de radiologie
que ce soit des services où on va faire
des diagnostics
on peut pas être heureux de dire qu'il
ya moins de soignants en france alors
que l'hôpital est déjà sous pression
donc on est effectivement dans un en
même temps tragique ou d'un côté il faut
le bâton et de l'autre la carotte or ça
ne marche pas dans un crise comme le co
vide on ne peut pas être réjouis de dire
que 3000 soignants sont suspendus quand
on a encore des malades 2000 malades
environ qui sont en urgence et quand ce
virus continue d'être là donc évaluer le
maquereau est en train de dire on est
méchant mais on est gentil en même temps
vous allez bientôt libéré de cette gang
qui est le passe à lithaire tout va bien
se passer ne vous inquiétez pas donc
c'est un peu le jeu du good cop bad cop
qu'on connaît dans les séries
américaines qui se joue à la française
en dix ans on est méchant à côté mais
gentil de l'autre donc il faut que vous
soyez patients les français et les pales
les français sont patients vraiment
parce que ce qui se passe c'est jouer
avec les nerfs en fait de la population
en disant pourquoi faut-il vacciner des
enfants pour qu'ils aillent jouer au
foot au tennis qu'ils aient dans des
clubs de judo alors que de l'autre côté
il ne risque rien et pourquoi de l'autre
côté on mobilise on immobilise des
soignants parce qu'ils n'ont pas choisi
de se vacciner il ya vraiment quelque
chose de l'ordre de l'ubuesque dans la
politique sanitaire depuis le début la
presse étrangère allemande par led
absurdistan autoritaire on est en plein
dans le dur de l'absurde distant et
autoritaire aujourd'hui avec la
suspension des soignants d'un côté et le
fait que le virus les chiffres sont bons
et ne permettent pas de dire que ces
mesures ont un sens aujourd'hui ces
mesures avaient un sens peut-être dans
l'été pour que les gens soient poussées
la vaccination est le sens du passé
éternité que ça pousse et les gens la
vaccination or la vaccination a ses
limites et or le virus va continuer donc
il va falloir lâcher du lest parce que
voir entrer bientôt en campagne et vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir stéphanie qui
monnayent macron est un candidat
permanent en campagne et là on le sait
ça devient évident avec ces annonces
aujourd'hui
j'allais y venir avec mon esprit
critique on va dire hé wenna quand se
réjouit il parle donc de lever 1 se
passe sanitaires mais d'autres quand
même autour de lui sont plus prudents le
conseil scientifique ou même son
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
c'est donc un président comme vous dites
non officiellement campagne qui parle
mais c'est encore un pari qu'il prend
emmanuel macron alors je pense que
départ il en a pris beaucoup
effectivement le premier pari c'était
quand même de dire aux français d'aller
au théâtre à une semaine de faire le
confinement absolue là c'était vraiment
le plus gros paraît qu'il ait jamais
pris ensuite ça a été une appropriation
de chaque instant il ya peu par idema le
maquereau en réalité il a essayé d'être
ce leader autoritaire absolue qui gère
par conseil de défense et d'être en même
temps le soignant le soignant absolue
qui donne des cadeaux qui dit aux
français qui les cajole en regarder ma
politique est tellement bonne que
maintenant vous pouvez sortir de votre
cage et c'est exactement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ne soyons pas dupe il sait
très bien que s'il veut gagner la
présidentielle de 2022 parce qu'il va se
représenter ne sommes pas dupes non plus
clairement mêmes macron n'a pas
l'intention de ne pas se représenter
comme françois hollande aujourd'hui donc
il fait tout pour lisser son image pour
colmater les brèches là où tout le monde
pourrait l'attaqué et ouroux est-ce
qu'on peut l'attaquer sur la sécurité
d'abord il a fait le boulot de la
sécurité cette semaine il était à
roubaix pour expliquer qu'il était le
président de la sécurité et la deuxième
attaque qui serait évidente c'est sur sa
gestion de cette crise qu vide qui a été
calamiteuse en rappelez vous le nous
sommes en guerre devant un hôpital
militaire sur un parking d'un
supermarché dans l'est de la france qui
n'avait aucun sens c'était simplement de
la mise en scène là aussi on pouvait le
critiquer en disant qu' il n'avait pas
de masque à l'époque et que sa porte
parole cib et n'diaye disait que les
basques étaient inutiles et que olivier
ferrand ministre de la santé lui-même
disait qu'à l'époque les masques étaient
inutiles aujourd'hui les masques ils
sont présents partout ils sont un
élément clé de la lutte contre le coc
vide donc le mensonge et l la
manipulation et l'improvisation est
telle qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
doit faire en sorte qu'ils il est
maintenant le président qui a vaincu
qu'ovide donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'il fait il dit que sa politique est
formidable que ces chiffres sont bons
que les français vont pouvoir après le
passé ni terre retrouvée non pas la vie
d'avant mais une vie adapté à la vie
qu'ovide et donc c'est ce qu'il fait en
tant que candidat permanent il est le
good cop et ses ministres vont être les
bad cop comme le conseil sanitaire qui
sera là pour lui rappeler que peut-être
il est trop tôt pour aujourd'hui dire
que le passé l'inter n'a plus de raison
d'être donc on n'en est pas là
évidemment ne pas sanitaire est toujours
très présent mais on voit bien que il ya
une volonté de se positionner comme
celui qui veut libérer les français
alors que c'est lui même emmanuel macron
qui nous a enfermés avec des autos
attestation de sortie avec des amendes
quand on allait se balader en forêt des
amendes sur la plage quand on voulait se
poser sur les plages de france
nous n'oublions pas comment le coc vide
a été un moment de n'importe quoi
pendant des mois parce que l'exécutif
mais pas seulement en france partout
dans le monde ne savais pas comment
réagir face à cette nouvelle maladie
aujourd'hui on a des moyens de lutter on
connaît un peu mieux le coville et idées
maintenant en france clair que la
campagne présidentielle a commencé et
qu'elle aime un grand compte bien être
candidat président et les voilà pourquoi
il fait ses annonces et voilà pourquoi
les ministres et le conseil de défense
sanitaire est aussi
bas de doute finalement de ses choix
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup alexis pour
l'un d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre analyse est la mobilisation
d'aidés soignants qui ne sont pas
vraiment en phase avec la stratégie du
gouvernement ils étaient une petite
centaine ce matin réunis devant les
locaux de l'ap-hp protestons contre
l'exclusion des 3000 personnel non
vaccinés au delà de la perte de salaire
les agents risquent de manquer au bon
déroulement des soins et de pousser
l'hôpital à fermer des lits on écoute
leurs réactions
on est dans une principe de contraintes
de vaccination sans convaincre et
maintenant depuis le15 tombe les
sanction de suspension sur des agents
qui d'ailleurs ont été au front pendant
plus d'un an et demi qui sont
indispensables dans les services et donc
la sq ont dénoncé qu'on va dénoncer ces
on va demander aucune suspension
notamment pour la fin déjà de faire en
sorte que l'ensemble des lits et l'offre
de soins sont ouvertes puisque par
ricochet les responsables qui sanctionne
et qu'ils suspendent vont impliquer des
fermetures de lignes loi sur l'hôpital
saint-antoine j'ai fait le tour un petit
peu fière et je voyais je constate que
de nombreux lits sont fermés on constate
que il va y avoir un problème pour la
prise en charge de nos patients des
patients qui ont attendus pratiquement
un an un an et demi avec cette crise
d'épidémie on leur a dit qu'on pouvait
pas les prendre en charge on a lu de la
chirurgie il ya des hauts des services
entiers qui annule des des opérations
parce qu'on manque d'effectifs et là
qu'est ce qu'on propose à nos
concitoyens on va les laisser mourir
chez eux après avoir été impacté par sa
course est promis ils vont mourir de
leur maladie chez eux et soigné en
colère vous venez de le voir on en parle
tout de suite avec véronique roger
médecins généralistes bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec direct sur rt france
3000 suspension à nous annoncer le
ministre de la santé ce matin de
soignants dont vacciner vous comprenez
ces soignants mécontent que l'on vient
d'entendre
bah oui tout à fait moi j'ai jamais
entendu autant de deux mots violents
pour
anvers des soignants je comprends pas ce
qui se passe c'est vraiment ce sont que
des mots comme se justifier des
sanctions
des contrôles
vous êtes interdit de pratiquer la
médecine enfin on n'a jamais entendu ça
c'est dans la bouche d'un état c'est
laid c'est incompréhensible 1,8 à oak
trail et doit être un peu d'empathie un
peu de remerciement on a on a applaudi
tous les soignants l'année dernière et
puis maintenant on les vire mais je
laisse ça dépasse mon entendement
je ne peux pas comprendre surtout bon on
était au front les premiers moi même
j'ai attrapé le coït parce que j'avais
pas de masse que l'année dernière
donc je comprends pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on me vire moi ça y est j'ai
arrêté mon activité hier je laisse 1500
patients sur le trottoir
c'est incompréhensible alors que
j'allais jouer au docteur roger à votre
situation évidemment on partait de ces
soignants et vous en faites partie vous
faites partie de ces soignants justement
ces médecins qui ne souhaitent pas se
faire vacciner qu'est ce qui s'est passé
clairement vous a dit fermer votre
cabinet racontez-nous
avenue on a reçu une note de la grèce en
plein mois d'août avec que des mots
violents et disant que de toute façon au
4 septembre
il fallait fermer sinon on était menacée
de sanctions pénales pénale c'est-à-dire
selon le l'article de la loi six mois de
prison dix mille euros damende mais
c'est complètement incompréhensible moi
j'arrive pas d'un exploit contre juan pu
s'adresser à nous comme ça
ben écoute et puisque moi je ne
comprends plus du tout ce genre de
médecine là c'est complètement hors de
mes deux mesures moi c'est pour une
médecine ethniques mais qui n'écoute je
comprends pas qu'on puisse être traité
comme ça bah ils veulent plus de moi bah
je m'en vais voilà c'est dramatique dont
mes patients mais je ne pardonnez moi où
justement vous en avait parlé avec vos
patients du fait que vous n'avez pas
envie de vous faire vacciner qu'est-ce
qui vous répondent eux
que très très variable en fait c'est pas
vraiment que j'ai pas envie et que j'ai
pas besoin il ya toute une partie de la
population qui a été complètement
occulté c'est tous les gens qui ont fait
le colis l'équipe des anticorps moi j'ai
toujours d'un anticorps je le vérifie de
temps en temps moi j'estime qu'il sera
pris en médecine que quand on avait des
anticorps on se remet à vacciner pas
derrière or là on est dans une folie
vaccinale on vaccine des gens qui ont
des anticorps quelques choix énorme
énorme on sait pas ce que ça peu de mes
pieds ça ça n'a pas de raison d'être ont
été alertés par une dame son fils à hulk
au vide un adolescent il a des anticorps
énormes qui sont même plus de sable ses
supérieurs à 250 et bien ce jeune là
qu'est tout à fait protéger et pas du
tout dangereux eh bien il a droit à rien
il n'a pas droit à son pass sanitaires
il faut qu'il soit vacciné mais c'est là
où je dis on est dans une folie
vaccinale vacciner des gens ont des
anticorps c'est une aberration et je
pense qu'on est des millions on est des
millions en france l'argument l'argument
qui consiste à dire qui ressort
évidemment dans ce débat sensible c'est
de dire voilà on se vaccine pas
nécessairement pour soi même mais aussi
et surtout pour les autres pour ne pas
contaminer peut-être des personnes
fragiles autour de soi qu'est ce que
vous répondez vous à cela
écoutez puisque j'ai des anticorps non
seulement je suis protégé mais je
protège les autres ça c'est une évidence
il ya avant de fermer la g j'ai
rencontré un patient qui avait été
vacciné deux fois
et qui jouit doser ses anticorps comme
ça pour voir parce que c'est quand même
intéressant de savoir aussi ce qui se
passe sur le terrain et ce monsieur
avait zéro anticorps pourquoi parce
qu'il avait une maladie auto immune ils
n'avaient pas développé des anticorps se
disait monsieur vous voyez le paradoxe
dont vous avez votre place vous pouvez
aller où vous voulez vous vous croyez
protéger donc peut-être que vous faites
moins d'attention et vous l'êtes pas du
tout et moi qui suis enfin de vous je
suis protégé je suis pas dangereuse
transit de si vous avez des anticorps
parce qu'on nous dit régulièrement le
contraire qu'on peut tout de même être
porteur et le transmettre y compris
quand on a des anticorps et non on peut
être vaccinés et et le transmettre mais
avoir des anticorps du manque mais mon
masque normalement normalement c'est bon
ben j'ai des noms plus cossus su
protéger se protège avec le maersk ces
bons doigts
mais alors que quand on nous dit tous
vaccinés tous protégés là c'est pas tout
à fait vrai parce que bon dans cette
crise aussi on n'est jamais allé
demander ce que les médecins
généralistes vilain
mais moi j'ai vu énormément de coliposte
vaccination
en tout cas
on vous aura donné nous la parole en
direct sur sur rt france merci véronique
roger et médecins donc généralistes
merci d'avoir été avec nous
et là et la campagne pour une troisième
d'eau se poursuit en france elle est
proposée depuis lundi aux personnes
fragiles notamment dans les ehpad mais
cette troisième injection divise pour l'
oms elle n'est pas justifiée david
khalifa
mieux vaut prévenir que guérir voilà
comment on pourrait vulgariser en une
expression l'injection d'une troisième
dose de vaccin mais à en croire certains
scientifiques elle n'est pas nécessaire
en tout cas pour une certaine catégorie
de personnes ems a vigoureusement
marquer son opposition à cette dose pour
demain pour l'instant nous ne souhaitons
pas que l'utilisation des rappels soit
généralisée pour les personnes en bonne
santé ou entièrement vacciner
calling for next je demande une
prolongation du moratoire au moins
jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour permettre
à chaque pays de vacciner au moins 40 %
de sa population le ti punch out of its
population oui car les doses n'étant pas
multipliable à l'infini donner plus de
vaccins à des états comme le nôtre pour
consolider notre immunité collective
entraîne mécaniquement un déséquilibre
entre les pays en voie de développement
et ceux qui sont développés un groupe
d'experts de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé et de la nva a donc pris le
taureau par les cornes en publiant une
étude pointue dans la revue scientifique
de 27 ans voici les conclusions
ces vaccins qui sont en quantités
limitées sauveront le plus de vie s'ils
sont fournis aux personnes qui ont un
risque important d'être atteint par une
forme grave du coc vide et non pas
encore été vaccinés les données
actuelles ne montre pas le besoin de
rappels de vaccins en population
générale chez laquelle l'efficacité
contre les formes graves reste élevé en
clair toutes les personnes qui se
rendent depuis lundi dans des centres de
vaccination comme celui qui se trouve
derrière moi pour une troisième dose
priverait d'une primo injection ceux qui
en ont vraiment besoin on regarde ces
chiffres il est vrai qu'on peut se
sentir quelque peu coupable près de 90%
des pays à revenu élevé et atteint
l'objectif des 10 % de la population
vaccinée et plus de 70 % et atteint la
barre des 40% en revanche par un seul
pays à faible revenu n'a atteint la ou
l'autre de ses buts d'où la question de
la nécessité de cette troisième dose
surtout que même parmi les populations
la couverture vaccinale est élevé la
minorité non vaccinés et qui demeure le
principal vecteur de transmission
présente elle même le plus grand risque
de maladie grave mais même si un gain de
protection peut être obtenue avec une
troisième dose ce gars ne l'emportera
pas sur les avantages de fournir une
première protection aux personnes non
vaccinées et si les vaccins sont
déployés là où ils sont le plus utiles
il pourrait accélérer la fin de la
pandémie en empêchant l'évolution des
variants une théorie difficiles à
vérifier puisque aucune étude ne le
montre pour le moment mais cela suscite
l'interrogation du reste pour l'om est
utilisé à des doses de vaccins déjà
existante serait inefficace selon
l'organisation mieux vaudrait porter ses
efforts sur le d autant de rappels armée
contre les variants les plus récents
notamment le delta et c'est là toute la
difficulté
l'efficacité des rappels développé
spécifiquement pour correspondre aux
nouveaux variants pourraient être plus
grandes et plus durable que celle des
rappels utilisant les vaccins actuels
bien que l'idée de réduire davantage le
nombre de cas de kovy 19 ans renforçant
l'immunité des personnes vaccinées soit
séduisante toute décision en ce sens
doit être fondée sur des preuves et
tenir compte des avantages et des
risques pour les individus et la société
le temps c'est de l'argent disait
benjamin franklin du temps les pays
riches n'en ont pas en tout cas ils ne
veulent plus en perdre pour obtenir la
preuve réelle d'une immunité renforcé
avec cette troisième dose le tout au
détriment des pays les plus pauvres
encore une fois ce qui pourrait avoir
des conséquences dramatiques cette
fois-ci
et certains pays justement sont déjà
confrontés à une quatrième vague de
l'épidémie c'est le cas d'israël les
autorités ont réussi à limiter l'impact
du covin notamment grâce à l'injection
d'une troisième dose de vaccin anti kovy
d'une stratégie contre l'avis de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé mais
qui permet au premier ministre israélien
n'a fait libé net de ne pas re confinés
comme il se l'était promis pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis tel
aviv avec paula slayer journalistes rt
internationale bonsoir paula
[Musique]
et bonsoir aulas quelle est la situation
sanitaire actuellement en israël
ribeauvillé se fait comme je suis apte
après les derniers chiffres dont nous
disposons il ya deux jours nous
enregistrons chaque jour en moyenne 8000
nouveaux cas de co vide parmi ces
nouveaux cas
de 60 à 70 personnes donc sérieusement
malade sookie et tout particulièrement
préoccupant c'est qu'une large partie de
ces cas surviennent parmi la jeunesse
nous avons connu une tendance
descendante pendant un certain temps
israël mais elle s'est inversée et le
ministère de la santé se prépare dès à
présent pour une heure 5e vav
nous faisons face la plus importante
vague de contaminations qu'israël ait
connu à ce jour il ya également beaucoup
de
discussions sur le système du passeport
au vert
le passeport vert est maintenu pour les
semaines et les mois à venir
évidemment on se pose la question on en
parlait justement avec ce docteur
français il y à il y à quelques minutes
des contaminations
malgré l'injection de vaccins c'est bien
ça mais peut-être pas de forme grave
c'est bien ça aussi
la nouvelle victime en du nouveau vaccin
les chiffres semblent indiquer qu'elle
est efficace cette vaccination
d'après le centre médical tel hashomer
de tel aviv 1 la troisième dose est
encore plus efficace qu'on ne le pensait
elle génère des niveaux d'anticorps dans
le corps jusqu'à 10 fois plus élevées
des niveaux d'anticorps après le second
vaccin
en israël 3 millions d'israéliens ont
reçu leur troisième dose
maccabi qui est un programme sanitaire
de santé en lancera elle a établi que le
vaccin est efficace à 86% contre
l'apparition de lakovic pour les
personnes de plus de 60 ans c'est le
côté positif du côté négatif les
tendances se montrent toujours hélas
encore beaucoup de questions notamment
pour les personnes une sur cinq
quasiment qui ont choisi de ne pas se
vacciner
65 %
de tout avec les formes graves de
coronavirus apparaissent parmi à cette
population non vaccinée
naftali bennett le premier ministre
israélien incite la population à se
faire vacciner
mais comme je les 10 17 % des israéliens
refusent toujours
israël s'apprête on a lu dans la presse
aujourd'hui à dégainer la grosse
artillerie technologique et a annoncé la
mise en place pour la d'un système
surnommé oméga capable de réaliser des
des scanners génétique qu'en est il
exactement
les listings on est encore au stade
préliminaire
il est piloté par le premier ministre
israélien ap tony bennett et il
développer car on redoute que les futurs
vague de coronavirus arriveront en
israël depuis les airs
comme est arrivé le variante lta alors
que le pays réussissait à endiguer la
maladie
depuis des mois les aéroports sont donc
restés fermés et on va lancer un
programme pilote plus tard dans l'année
qui permettra à des gens ne se rendent
en israël à s'ils ont été vaccinées deux
fois s ils ont été testés dans les 48
heures avant leur arrivée
ce programme qui comme vous l'avez
mentionné
s'appelle programme eau mega permet à
leur arrivée à l'aéroport de ben gourion
la porte principale à tel aviv d'être
scannées de créer un séquençage
génétique afin de vérifier si
il y à présence de variants ou de forme
du corona virus
car on doute que le prochain variant
pourrait arriver via les un trajet
aérien
au programme donc pas encore en place
mais devrait l'être très bientôt
merci paul à slayer en direct de
tel-aviv merci d'avoir été avec nous et
c'est la fin de cette émission
rendez vous lundi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro en attendant l'actualité
évidemment continue pour commencer à 22
heures pour un point complet sur
l'actualité
[Musique]